alors c'était une télévision locale
non parce que là je commence quand même
que c'est une télévision locale
[Musique]
il est installé la côte et c'est comme
ça que disais que j'allais souvent les
rois venaient chez nous aussi
pas tous les jours mais souvent aussi
[Musique]
sympa
est-ce qu'on pourrait bien leur
passéisme aussi inquiétant que tu veux
nous verrons donc le comice aussi qu'on
bat saint nom de jésus avant
l'anniversaire de la libération des cinq
secondes de ce 100ème anniversaire de la
fanfare de gier communautaire ouverte et
retiennent locale associative commercial
subventionner le topic de foire
permanente éphémère libre rurale urbaine
de campagne riche pauvre alternative
régionaliste en apnée sous perfusion de
sa non de quartier d'immeubles satellisé
à la carte câble et abstract juvénile
pirates joyeux sérieux aventurière
expressionniste du comique et brouettes
c'est pas de l'info locale on n'est pas
des localiers on n'est pas comme les
flics qui vont autour d'un secteur pour
dire c'est mon coin
il faut habiter il faut vivre là il faut
vivre dans le secteur dans dans le
dans le pays pour pouvoir faire une
télévision locale deux pays
la télé brouette télé sauget existe
matin depuis sept ou huit ans elle
commence à se poser beaucoup de
questions des questions financières des
questions techniques et même des
questions existentielles
les anciens bénévoles et donc tout ça
dans l'abbaye de montbenoît sa bande de
copains
franchement c'était de journalistes
comme ça alors on allait tout changer
non c'est un truc que tu veux pas dire
c'est fédéral n'a jamais des
journalistes m s'il n'y a pas une fête
pour la neige tout le monde souhaite
la leyenda on a quand même fait là où ça
fait du journalisme
oui tu crois on a filmé en gt1 au rex
était en 206 là un chapiteau s'est
écroulé ils sont on était là pour filmer
mes idées je n'hésite pas du rallye
c'était on était vraiment la télé locale
on n'a pas fait le travail de réaliste
avec des commentaires plus ou moins des
pages on est tous comme relevant de l'ag
mais suivent leur portée par derrière
celles citées par les relater est belle
mais quand même et les différentes
façons de rennes et oui on ne sait pas
comment derrière voilà
de toute façon si un journaliste
intervient dans la conversation il va
diriger effectivement nous n'étions pas
journaliste est de toute façon
à chacun son regard et le reportage
n'allez pas toujours dans le sens du
poil
au début si tu es si c'est bien parce
que soit porté une petite notoriété mais
par moments vont vous avez la caméra
dans les mains vous allez un peu fort
contre nous mais bon si tu es normal
monstre que je me souviens parce que
quand même 25 ans faut 6 1
ce que je me souviens assez cotisé
mélenchon et leurs cd4 neiges de
montbenoit qui était une grosse manif
400 bénévoles à gros budget et tout et
puis ce jour la télé sauget ne trouve
rien de mieux dans son dos son compte
rendu de nouveau film est une grande
horloge au niveau du poids de montbenoit
en rappelant qu'on avait deux ou trois
ans de retard par rapport aux résultats
des coureurs qui passait à côté sais pas
mais c'est qu'il aime la caméra et que
tenait une caméra on peut jouer avec un
on peut passer ce qui est bien ce qui
est moins bien puisque est moyen en
disant bon on reste dans un créneau
correct et là je pense qu'à ce niveau là
td sogem un petit peu débordé trois
dérapages
[Musique]
c'est important c'était quand même en
principe celui qui avait fait le mic
essayer de venir me désole de ce que je
sais c'est pas mal mais attend oui il
faut y ajouter j'allais voir que tu
montais tiens voilà ce qu on a monté
notre intellect je reviendrai le dit je
vais prendre le café je vais prendre le
café ce bout-là qui disait aux autres à
un beau jeu coûte et puis je disais non
je suis passé il somme c'est pas mal ça
arrive et des trois couleurs bbox ne
lèverait pas bon vous faites comme vous
tous si ces films étaient plutôt
bénéfique pour le secteur
1 parce qu'il filmait une réunion du
film et on sera ensemble ça ne pouvait
que donner un avantage aux collectivités
je pense qu'il aurait pu avoir un peu
plus d'ampleur
s'ils vont si la suite si la population
a été plus importante c'était le monde
d'habitants et on peut ne peut pas
programmer pour de 3000 habitants
ce qu'on aurait pu faire dans une toute
petite dans une petite ville où une
agglomération l'importante dans cet être
restreint même dans les zones rurales
défavorisées les télés locales se sont
développées par exemple dans le limousin
télé millevaches
c'est vraiment une initiative de gens
qui disent on est sur un territoire on
vit on est bien sur ce territoire ont
fait beaucoup de choses et l'image qu'on
est du pays dans lequel on vit est
inverse de ce que l'on ressent de ce que
l'on croît de ce que l'on fait tous les
jours on va on va prendre une caméra
pour pour renverser ce regard cette
image et pour montrer justement que
c'est pas le cas donc vraiment télé
millevaches c'était ça je crois que
c'est le plus important c'est des
habitants qui à un moment prennent la
parole
en fait ils prennent la parole devant
une caméra pour prendre la parole pour
montrer à leurs voisins et ensuite mais
ce n'était pas le but premier à
l'extérieur du plateau qui se passe ici
des choses est que le plateau de
millevaches et pas si mort que ça quoi
bonjour à tous merci alors vu évidemment
tout de suite on s'est dit ça ya des
gens qui font la même chose que nous
ailleurs il faut absolument qu'on allait
voir
et donc tout de suite télé millevaches a
essayé de se mettre en contact avec ces
gens c'est comme ça qu'on a entendu
parler puis rencontrer les gens de télé
sauget qui à l'époque faisait figure
d'ancêtre c'était une 1978 c'était
souvent des télévisions qui était d'un
milieu rural
donc en fait il y avait monté les sauges
évidemment dans le jura il y avait le
temps moliner qui était au fin fond des
monts d'arrée enfonce entre des monts
d'arrée il y avait la télé gazette qui
était dans les alpes de haute provence
il y avait vidéothèque trégor donc
cesser télévision avait quand même des
points qui les rassemble et c'était
vraiment la volonté de représenter leur
territoire et de montrer que finalement
on n'était pas plus que d'un saut j'ai
que en tout cas c'est tout qu'ils
étaient aussi intéressant que ce qu'on
voyait à côté et qui a pas de raison ces
gens là il n'est jamais accès à la télé
quoi il n'avait jamais accepté des dons
qu'elle avait pas de raison
pour s'entraider et se faire connaître
la plupart des télés locales se sont
réunies en créant la fédération et des
vis de pays et des quartiers ces
télévisions elles ont quand même partagé
tout aussi une précarité absolument
extraordinaire c'est à dire que c'est
des gens qui n'avaient pas ou très très
peu de subventions car elle en avait
c'est un tout petit peu de la commune
qu'elle même était tout petit donc avait
pas d'argent ou un tout petit peu du
conseil général éventuellement un moment
pour des opérations de préfiguration de
télévision locales elles ont eu quelques
financements de la data mais c'était
quand même très très marginale donc j'ai
laissé des groupes qui n'avait pas
d'argent donc ce n'était pas un marché
pour qui c'était un marché pour
quiconque
larhant 82 le nouveau gouvernement lance
un plan câble assez ambitieux mais ce
plan va connaître des vicissitudes dans
sa mise en oeuvre est retardée notamment
à cette époque se pose la question du
contenu canal local qui rend compte de
la vie locale du du pays et pour
faciliter cette production de programmes
la data c'est plus l'aménagement du
territoire et la mission câble lance un
plan de soutien à cette production qui
va à 6 nourrir ces nouvelles télévisions
proximité
[Musique]
quand sont mineurs s'en va la voir son
petit coeur soupir
qu'avez vous donc à soupe iris si cela
la pauline a fait ça qu'avez vous donc à
soupirer a soupiré et à pleurer si je
pleure son nid pointe aux gens qu'on est
bien la cause
ah si je pleure jaunies pointeau j'en
connais bien la cause
on entend dire par deux sur tout ceci
cela la pauline peyssard on entend dire
par deux surtout que je suis enceinte de
vous situer enceinte de moi c'est bien
par ta bêtise et je t'ai vie plus de 100
fois ceux ci à la pauline a fait ça et
je dis plus de 100 fois que je ne
trouverais pas à si tu veux pas
m'épouser
dans deux mois donc pour vivre si tu
veux pas m'épouser dans le moison pour
vivre dans le moins 5 à 6 aux français
si cela la paulina paix ça donne moins 5
à 6 offrant pour nourrir la mère et
l'enfant 5 à 6 ans c'est un peu tort
pour un mineur pas riche
[Musique]
quand la pauline va au marché par ce tir
des cerises
elle met son beau tablier blanc ceci
cela la paulina pessah elle met son beau
tablier blanc pourrait cacher son
accident
[Applaudissements]
quelques temps après pour la mission
câble nous produisons une longue série
qui va être distribué dans toutes les
huit câbles et de france
ses documentaires destinés à une
diffusion extérieur nous ont permis de
dépasser enfin pour la première fois la
fameuse telemiroir la série les
montagnes ont présenté 12 facettes de la
vie en moyenne montagne
en s'attachant à laisser la parole aux
gens et en évitant les clichés passéiste
par exemple des petits documentaires sur
lies club de foot
la double activité les bals du samedi
soir les petits bistrots ou encore les
correspondants locaux du journal
régional
j'aime bien je passe pas mal de temps
mais ça y est je trouve intéressant puis
on ne sait dire si j'ai peur que ce soit
pas transmise au journal des fonds isr
je sais ce que l'article arrive je
m'inquiète tout le temps c'est ce
contact avec ce contact avec la
population
et puis relaté c'est l'amour du pays
montrer que j ai est un village
dynamique en pleine expansion mais
surtout c'est toujours dans le souci de
rendre service aux gens ont fait par le
journal pour gagner de l'argent
donc ça fait une fois dire honnêtement
ça fait une bonne can you autrement au
départ on fait pas ça pour de l'argent à
7 francs pour une plante qui paraît et
puis 10 centimes pour une ligne
j'aime bien écrire j'aime j'aime bien
faire des articles
je relate publiés
les fêtes les tournées les mariages les
décès
[Musique]
alors les mots tagnon c'est une série
qui nous a pris un an de travail pour
dire que tous ces films
douze films d'un quart d'heure se
déroule sur toute une année
on peut prendre facilement prendre le
temps pour filmer
on habite sur place on n'a pas cinq
heures de route pour pour trouver la
bonne interlocuteur c'est des gens que
l'on côtoie tous les jours on les
connaît on a besoin de la pelote coupe
au téléphone
dix minutes après on peut tourner ce
plan on a pas on n'a pas un gros
problème d'organisation
cette série destinée une très large mais
passagère exploitation fut appréciée par
les montagnons l eso j'ai
malheureusement notre système de
diffusion télé bref je n'évolue pas et
même se compliquer à les convergences ça
suffit pas parce que si on ne fait rien
dans ces forêts là mais d'ici 20 ans la
forêt y en aura plus c'est à dire que
les arbres seront secs seront mamba ya
qu à voir d'ailleurs leur tête pour le
moment comment déjà être pratiquement au
bout du rouleau et même titre que quand
bush mais des carottes
si vous voulez l'essayer tout il ne
restera que des crayons et bien on
enlève un sur deux à sur trois pour que
ceux qui restent et plus de place aussi
bien au niveau de leurs cimes au niveau
de leurs racines pour pouvoir grossir en
diamètre et ça s'appelle des éclaircies
un numéro d'ordre numéro trois c'est
cette marque là qui permet de repérer
les arbres qui vont être vendus
530000 4230 1128 1126 1124 me sens de
826 en 1816 1100 4112 810 108 107 106
1453 son fils à qui un cari ville pour
faire 21 la coupe pour le rangement
j'avais déjà dépanné comme le temps
clément sa dépendent bien des choses
n'est pas aux pièces vous prend combien
quinze jours dans l'année un mois au
plus que ça on vient d'en fabriquer pas
se voir vous maintenant qu'elle a fait
ses preuves et les sauges aimerait bien
améliorer ses moyens de diffusion pour
le câble rien de possible avant quinze
ou vingt ans
les contacts avec fr3 pour disposer d'un
temps d'antenne ou encore rien donné
reste la distribution et tiennent des
pourparlers sont en cours avec une ou
deux télévisions dans chaque village les
4637 habitants du canton pourrait enfin
tous en même temps se regarder causer
dans le poste que telle est sûre j'ai
patienté faire 3 accueillera d'autres
télévisions seulement quand le parlement
lors a décidé c'est lui qui décide ça ne
va pas être facile de faire évoluer
notre mode de diffusion
mais on continue à y réfléchir
le maitien sera pas avant trois faire
comme ça qu'on va pas y avoir d'accord
john d'occasion veut commander militaire
fait désordre sur canal on va aller pas
évident de trouver le canal apparemment
il faut un gars qui a un détecteur de
change qui connaît un bon et des gares
boutiques qui sont pour 25000 francs que
nous a fabriqué un des gamins à lyon qui
va voir lesquels même pour 6 millions 5
sont à différents genres peut-être
trouvé et puis comment on va faire
comment l'aider à ce serait quand même
de faire des maîtres une fois par
semaine un petit truc né serait-ce
qu'une demi-heure fait opposition
nous sommes en 93 après mac luhan toute
la gaule est occupée par les networks
tout non un village peuplé
d'irréductibles faiseurs d'image résiste
encore et toujours aux despotes éclairés
de la tv et la vie catholique n'est pas
facile pour ces aventuriers des camps
retranchés du village global de la
chaude juillet et qui se bat pour que
cesse le ronflement persistant du
téléviseur
lorsque le zappeur cherche désespérément
son canal local dès 1983 on envisageait
déjà des modes de diffusion d'hiver
jusqu'au plus utopique et ont cherché
des appuis tous azimuts
[Musique]
je pense que l'avenir de votre
télévision sera bon parce que vous êtes
une bonne télévision
actuellement il ya une demande de
télévision évidemment il va y avoir
d'autres chaînes il n'y aura plus de
concurrence
les foules à vous entendre avec la
chaîne régionale ou une autre pour avoir
quelques créneaux
alors offrez un petit peu de télévision
livre comme vous faites un petit peu de
télévision affiliés associé à la chaîne
la plus proche voilà comment je vois
votre affaire c'est que je suis un peu
changé par le choeur saint loup vrai
sujet jean raffolent de la bei datcha
déjà il est en mode
moi je suis tout à fait favorable au
développement des télévisions locales
naturellement avec un minimum d'ordre et
de discipline pour que ligne ehpad
d'interférences technique mais j'y suis
tout à fait favorable et je vous
souhaite la meilleure le meilleur de
développement et meilleur d avenir
moi je pense qu' il serait intéressant
pour télé pour les télévisions comme
telle et sauget de subir peut-être
l'expérience de la diffusion je pense
que de toute manière pour eux comme pour
les autres télévisions rural ce serait
un changement un changement notable et
dans leur façon d'être perçue par leur
environnement et peut-être aussi dans
les façons de travailler
je sais pas si je serai bien ou mal en
tous les cas ce sera différent mais vous
vous saviez prête à faire une démarche
auprès du président la république par
exemple ou quelqu'un d'autre pour
autoriser télé soja et m je peux bien
faire la demande c'est pareil à ce
douloureux
monsieur mitterrand c'est mon collègue
ils n'oseront pas me refuser ça j'espère
cette histoire des maîtres quand même ça
titille et beaucoup de monde
oui alors on est en 1982 changement de
majorité et il y a le vote d'une loi qui
supprime le monopole de programmation
donc vont apparaître des télévisions
commerciales nationales financées par la
publicité mais aussi ce mouvement
succède à cette période où des
télévisions des radios au pardon des
radios libres sont apparus dans le pays
elles ont été légalisés elle aussi en 80
et puis par la loi de 82 mais les
télévisions associatives pirates vont
émettre parce qu'elles ne sont pas à
égaliser
donc on voit apparaître quelques
télévisions qui émerge à paris et en
province qui sont des télévisions de
pirates qui émettent inégalement la des
épisodes importants je crois qu'il
compte en tout cas de de la progression
de la démocratie dans le monde de
l'audiovisuel a été hanté nain à la télé
pirate libre associative antennes un
conte a créé en 1982 dans la foulée de
carbone 14 qui a joué un rôle important
aussi dans les radios libres
on a acheté clandestinement en italie a
même et or on n'a pas senti les états
chez parce que c'était interdit
d'acheter des émetteurs de télévision en
france d'ailleurs on n'en trouvait pas
donc on assure nathalie la fais pas ça
me détacher et puis on avait notre
émetteur à l'infini collecte d'ailleurs
très large pour pouvoir payer cet
émetteur sa coûter un peu plus cher
qu'aujourd'hui mais et on a commencé de
manière très légère puisque tout n'est
dans quelques valises et quelques mal à
couvrir les toits en étant très mobiles
puisqu'on était menacée de saisie en
permanence
aquarelles de toi pour faire des
lyon pirates en faisant passer l'info
par les radios libres de l'époque disant
voilà aujourd'hui antennes 1 diffuse
depuis telle toi dentelle direction
mettez vous sur tel canal hertzien pour
le recevoir ses programmes et non
seulement on l'a fait à paris mais on
l'a fait aussi en province étaient une
télé qui démontrait finalement qu'on
pouvait faire de la télévision
dans une économie associative et que
tout le monde devait six mètres après
avoir fait les radios on avait fait
relais télé me pendre à les gagner
[Applaudissements]
ce qui nous a certainement manqué à ce
moment-là ce soit les connexions avec
les réseaux militants pour faire évoluer
notre système mais en attendant et
tournai le tour de france
[Applaudissements]
c'est un petit peu travailler la
souplesse
pour ça fait chuter plusieurs fois entre
autres les vedettes de la télé match à
willows inn et qu'ils avaient bien qu'on
a pris la peine après le pôle vente
léon zitrone m'a rattrapé pas mais un
journaliste sportif de france de pro
tour de france à l'arrivée où l'harmonie
on tournait un peu comme ça j'ai du coup
on s'appelle le gardeur il a dit qu'est
ce que vous faites
qu'est ce que vous faites avec votre
caméra a viré de laisser au travail et
qu'on n'a jamais été pris avec elle
paris match
lemay le meilleur jeu doit inaugurer la
télé gucci mane mis à jour et c'est bien
ce que vous faites mais exposé pas un
jour quand même de faire de la vraie
télé au niveau régional notre chaîne fr3
sera bien sûr toujours présente mais ne
sera donc plus la seule à vous proposer
des programmes locaux en franche comté
deux nouvelles chaînes privées locales
pourrait voir le jour d'ici à 1986 six
dossiers ont déjà été déposés dans ce
sens auprès de la haute autorité auquel
s'ajoutera celui de télé sauge et la
plus ancienne télévision privée qui
fonctionne dans notre région
entraînement à notre meilleure diffusion
est périmé c'est à dire aller de village
en village est de faire rentrer les gens
c'est périmé alors je pense que si on
peut aller chez les gens ça sera mieux
vous avez bon espoir que ce projet soit
accepté
on a bon espoir mais
je crains qu'il y ait beaucoup d'un
bouche lesquels tu auras une ancienne
pour nous et skhira de la place 1
on est en zone frontière on est dans la
montagne on n'a pas les bonnes
conditions pour l'instant à au moins du
point de vue m quel est le principal
avantage pour refonder cette télé locale
on sera certainement une des rares
télévision locale à avoir des archives
[Musique]
comme nous n'avons pas réussi à résoudre
tous les problèmes techniques financiers
juridiques pour créer une télé locale de
plein exercice
c'est à dire une vraie télé nous avons
fait beaucoup de cirque auprès des
autorités pour qu'elles nous prennent
enfin article au sérieux et nous avons
obtenu en 1988 pour l'occasion notre
dixième anniversaire une autorisation
temporaire des maîtres pendant dix jours
mais suite au prochain numéro
[Musique]
il
on
vous voulez dire ceux présents jonglage
amour et falbalas une symphonie un feu
d'artifice de grands sentiments